for decades china has been working on
catching up to the us
economically and technologically
throughout the late 1900s
their efforts paled in comparison to the
explosive growth of the u.s
as they solidified their position as a
global supplier however
their gdp skyrocketed at this rate
most economists agreed that it's just a
matter of time
until china's gdp surpasses the gdp of
the us
this brings up the question is gdp the
only segment that the chinese will
dominate
or will the success spill over to the
space industry as well
unlike the ussr and the u.s china was a
relatively late entrant into space
the other space agency the cnsa was also
founded during the cold war
they were never thought of as a space
superpower it was until the last 20
years that china really started to make
significant progress with their rocket
technology
but within that short period of time
china's growth has been
relentless and it seems like they might
even have a chance to beat nasa to mars
so we'll take a look at 5 different
categories just like last week with our
nasa vs russia video
starting with launch technology before
we jump into launch technology though
i wanted to mention that we won't be
including spacex in this video
as this is a comparison between nasa and
china
not spacex in china the one exception to
that role
is when we are analyzing nasa's cost
efficiency though nasa
can't take credit for spacex's rocket
technology they can take credit for
cleverly investing into spacex through
the commercial crew program
with that being said let's jump into the
launch technology of
nasa in terms of in-house rockets nasa
doesn't really have any they were
initially relying on russia to send us
astronauts to space
and now they're relying on private
companies they have been working on a
behemoth rocket though called the space
launch system
or sls this rocket was originally
approved in august of 2014
with an expected launch date of
september 2018.
clearly that didn't happen but nasa is
finishing off the final tests
and they're planning to conduct the
first uncrewed launch in november
so it does seem like sls will finally
take fight within the next 12 months
when it takes flight it will no doubt be
a monster as it's supposed to have a
payload capacity
of 70 metric tons nasa also has plans to
eventually produce a larger variant with
130 metric tons of pillar capacity
as for china they have a lot of rockets
and i honestly have no idea why
china currently has 24 different rockets
out of which 7 are retired
15 are active and 2 are in development
the active rockets included long march
2c 2d 2f 3a
3be 3c 4b 4c
5 5b6788 and 11.
considering the amount of rockets they
have it's not surprising to hear that
they complete the most number of
launches
annually in the world most of these
rockets have a payload capacity
of three to seven metric tons the
smallest rocket of the bunch
is the long march 6 which only has a
pillar capacity of 500 kilograms on the
other end of the spectrum
the largest rocket is the long march 5b
which has a pillar capacity of 25 metric
tons
as for the rockets in development we
have the long march 6a
and the long march 9. we don't have too
many details about the 6a
but china has revealed that they're
going all out with the long march 9.
this rocket is expected to support a
payload capacity of up to 150 metric
tons
if successful the long march 9 would be
the largest rocket
ever built the rocket isn't expected to
take flight till 2030
but something to keep in mind is that
china is actually pretty good
at hitting their deadlines so it's quite
likely that we will see the long march 9
take flight
in the early 2030s aside from having a
plethora of launch vehicles
china is also heavily focusing on
reusability
they're currently trying to land along
march 8 vertically just like the falcon
9.
china also has a goal of achieving full
reusability by 2035 meanwhile
nasa basically gave up on reusability
they tried to make a reusable rocket
with the space shuttle
but that ended up costing way too much
to reuse so
they're not even trying to make sls
reusable given china's vast fleet of
rockets
and their ambitions for massive reusable
rockets i think that the launch
technology point has to go to china
moving on to reliability this is a
completely different story
nasa used to be heavily praised for its
reliability back in the apollo days with
saturn 5
which boasted a 100 success rate when it
came to the space shuttle though
nasa fell out of the spotlight nasa
built a total of six space shuttles
but only five of these were ever used
for space missions
the last space shuttle or i guess
technically the first space shuttle
was called enterprise and it was built
for atmospheric testing purposes
out of the five that did complete space
missions though two of them
were lost meaning that forty percent of
the space shuttles built for actual
missions
were lost when it comes to reliability
the russian soyuz rocket is really the
gold standard
soyuz rockets have completed upwards of
2000 launches
out of which only one led to a fatality
compared to that the space shuttle holds
no water but when we compare the space
shuttle to chinese reliability
the space shuttle is actually quite
favorable here's the thing
china has a problem with rockets and
boosters getting out of control during
re-entry
chinese rocket debris often lands in
nearby villages causing significant fear
and some damage scientists have
calculated that given the massive
surface area of the earth
it's unlikely that this debris will
cause serious damage
but the principle that the chinese are
just letting their rocket debris land
wherever
is terrible this negligence makes it
clear that china values ford progress
much more than ensuring safety and
reliability and this alone disqualifies
them from winning the reliability point
so nasa gets the reliability point tying
up the competition
next up let's take a look at either
country's upcoming space projects
and missions since 2000 china has been
obliterating nasa
in terms of their space ambitions nasa
hasn't really done anything new
in quite some time and this has given
china the perfect opportunity to
overtake nasa
china has already started to overtake
nasa in some aspects
for instance in 2019 china became the
first country to make a soft landing
on the dark side of the moon with changi
iv
at the end of 2020 china became the
first country to bring back lunar
samples to the earth
since 1967. in may
china also became the second country to
successfully land a rover
on mars also did i mention that china
was banned from the iss due to a lack of
transparency
and instead of complying they decided to
just build their own
clearly china isn't messing around and
they have results to back up their
efforts
they're also not just satisfied with
mid-tier space achievements
they have their eyes on the most
prestigious space achievements such as
sending humans to the moon
and mars currently china's plan is to
complete a crude lunar mission in the
2030s
using the upcoming long march 9. nasa is
still looking to return to the moon in
and though i'm not confident that 2024
will pan out
i am confident that nasa will do it by
this means that nasa will return to the
moon before china reaches the moon
if we look at mars however nasa's lead
isn't nearly as clear
china is looking to go to mars right
after their lunar mission
in fact they think they can do it as
early as 2033
now i would say that it's very possible
and even likely that spacex beats china
to the red planet
but will nasa beat china using sls i'm
not so sure
nasa might use starship to send their
astronauts to mars before china
but that's not the same thing as nasa
reaching mars using their own rocket
given how much china has caught up and
the fact that they may even beat nasa to
mars
i think that china has the edge when it
comes to upcoming space projects
and missions completing such ambitious
space missions
is awesome but what would make it even
more impressive is completing them for a
reasonable price
and that brings us into our fourth
category which is cost efficiency
china is quite secretive about their
launch costs but they have revealed a
couple
here and there the long march 3b for
instance costs 50 to 70 million dollars
that's about the same amount that nasa
has to pay spacex to launch a falcon 9
rocket
however the thing to note is that falcon
9 has over doubled the payload capacity
of long mars 3b
so nasa's investment into the commercial
crew program has given them a much more
cost effective launch option
nasa's also looking to use a lunar
starship to send humans to the moon
and i'm pretty confident that starship
will be much more cost efficient than
china's upcoming long march 9
as spacex has much more experience when
it comes to rocket reusability
so nasa gets the point for cost
efficiency
and that leaves us with one last
category which is innovation
and longevity once again this should be
two different categories
but like the comparison between nasa and
russia either nasa
nor china is really that innovative
today
nasa has stalled for decades and china
is just copying rocket technology from
all around the world
so i don't think either nasa or china
deserve the innovation point
which just leaves us with longevity
longevity
is a pretty complicated answer as we all
know
china is more or less just copying
technology from various parts of the
world
but that can actually last quite a long
time just take a look at the ussr
and the us both countries were really
just copying german rocket technology
and were relying on german scientists to
push forward their space programs
however the us ended up winning the
space race because they were able to
innovate past german technology
and reach the moon meanwhile the soviet
union
never really got out of the copying
stage despite that though
innovation didn't provide an immediate
end to the rivalry between the two
countries
the cold war started in 1947 and the u.s
reached the moon in 1969
but the cold war didn't end till 1991
which is
22 years later so copying can last for
quite a while
as we've seen in the past whether china
will stop copying and start innovating
is yet to be seen and we won't find out
for decades
it's very possible that china copies
starship for the next 20 years and
reaches mars
but once they reach mars they start
innovating and become the leaders of the
colonization effort
or maybe copying alone is not enough for
them to reach mars
and as they see spacex win the race to
mars they might slowly stall out like
the ussr
i am biased towards american capitalism
and entrepreneurship
so i'm gonna say that nasa is going to
win this category
and that they will be the future rulers
of space with the help of their private
space industry
with that being said i would not be
surprised to see china pick up the slack
within the next 20 years
and dominate the next space race either
way though i'm convinced that the two
leading space superpowers moving forward
will be america and china so the race
will not be boring
by any means do you guys think that
china could overtake the us
comment that down below also drop a like
if you're rooting for team america
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one